why have i got three sisters here okay
that's the question if god says it
then i definitely think that is better
it's not what the father said is that
you don't like it because it touched a
nerve with you and that's why you're
responding in that way
like for example without my hijab i go
to like a solid like eight out of ten
appearance like attraction-wise
and with the hijab i'm like you know a
two you know if i'm choosing to dress
the way i dress
and they they take these pictures with a
hijab before and then their
picture now of their freedom all of
their pictures are all
in revealing clothing and they deem this
to be i now
free and i've made this truth and that's
why we think subconsciously that it's
my choice but even psychologists and
people around that have studied have
shown
how much we are influenced
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah welcome
to this unique
reaction video yes why have i got three
sisters here okay that's a question
that everybody would be asking well the
reason why i've got this
resistance is because i've done a lot of
videos when it comes to the issue of
hijab i would say hijab per se but it's
been like maybe hijabi youtubers
maybe talking about the hijab men's
hijab etc and a lot of people in the
comment section say you know what
why don't you it's a sister's topic why
do you you shouldn't talk about it which
i i don't believe in that concept but
you know but they say it's important to
have the sisters to stay on it and i
think it's
it's important it's a valid point but
i'm not to blame because
do we have reliable influences out there
uh
there might be some i don't know so i
was thinking look you know what
there's there was a video that was sent
to me from a youtube called they called
jubilee something and there's a
three sisters well they're six sisters
six muslims three hijabi free non-hijab
and some people were like can you react
to that
and i thought yeah i can and i was
recently um having a bit of a
heated discussion with certain ex-muslim
females
and i noticed something in them which
we're going to come to but this is the
reason why we have the three sisters
because i want to hear it from the
sisters i want to
speak to our dear sister sister farzana
may allah bless her sister naima and
sister
may allah bless you guys for joining us
can you just briefly before we start
just tell us a bit about yourselves
and what you do quickly and then we'll
get into the reaction video my name is
uh
and um i work with sisters martial as a
marriage and healing coach so i just
help them
navigate through their relationship and
if they're having any difficulties
and just coach them on that and sisters
who have been through a divorce
and just help them to heal through that
process
thank you so much for having me today
i'm mohammed i'm also a qualified life
coach and
nlp practitioner helping people through
their challenges whether it's in their
relationships
or in their careers and i also raise
current issues
on several different tv channels as a
presenter and a producer
when i stop it we elaborate on here
oh
i'm shocked i'm sitting here when we
read the quran we get
our own interpretations of it but
it does say that in there to only show
your hands face and feet
if god says it then i definitely think
that
is better but i don't think the behavior
of
acting like you're better than someone
that i don't
see that's right she said what allah
commands in the quran is
she acknowledges that that is good for
her but she doesn't like the fact
that other people wear the hijab looking
down at others
don't so we can all agree on that right
but this doesn't give a right to anybody
to look down
at someone else we agree or does anybody
want to elaborate um of course
i agree but i think yes we need to
elaborate as to what she really means
and i think what she really means is
that
there's so-called uh religious police
out there and
there has to be a clock even when you
are delivering a message
it has to be a message where it's
actually inviting and welcoming and it
has to be something where
it can actually influence in a good way
instead of turning people
uh further away that's my understanding
um
i wonder how much of this type of
conversation
is people projecting their own
insecurities
onto others and i'm not saying that
there are not
those of us or people out there who
judge
and who are mean about things and harsh
and you know just
out of bounds and not in keeping with
the aflac of a muslim
but i think that there is also a
projection that happens where people
feel judged they feel like someone is
being harsh
they are expecting a bad response and so
when they get a response that's how they
interpret it and i think
that's something that we all need to be
careful of as well because
the problem with kind of saying oh i
you know i don't like the way they those
who are doing the thing the way they
behave with me it makes me not want to
do the thing
you're basically giving power to people
who
don't know you they they don't know you
they don't know your life they don't
know anything but you're giving them
this power
to affect how you practice your deen and
i
feel like that's not something we should
encourage because
every one of us is on our own journey
like we're all here
we're going to go back to allah
returning directly to answer to him
and other people's behavior with us is
not an excuse
so i'm not saying this to be harsh and
i'm not saying this to be
religious police or anything but every
one of us needs to also be
cognizant of the fact that sometimes
it's not what the sister said
it's not what the father said is that
you don't like it because it touched the
nerve with you
it hit a raw nerve it made you insecure
it reminded you that
you're maybe not where you know you
could be and that's why you're
responding in that way
you know what that's interesting because
as you carry on the video this is the
complex something interesting i actually
have so much to say about this
so far it's dark okay i think a lot of
people think that it's like a point
system
oh yes hijab ding you know like next
level and i don't think
god is like this person wears the hijab
you're good to go
versus this person doesn't so and you're
out i think everything else that you do
weighs in i do know many hijabis that
like do not follow anything else
and i know a lot of non-hijabis that are
the most religious you know women that
i've ever met i have a friend on like
instagram who dresses however she wants
to dress and she could rock it she has a
body for it
but she goes to every friday prayer and
i'm like
all right so now this is very this is a
little bit interesting here but this is
not one of the reasons why i wanted to
do this video yeah but let's just
address it
sister farzana do you think she has a
point in the context where she's saying
hold on a second yeah
and i've seen this in my life for
example i can remember when i was in
knightsbridge and it was time for
maghrib
and usually i do uber slows like
part-time and sometimes i have to stop
and pray so i have a prayer might have
to go outside and pray
i was and this is this was very
interesting to me because i don't know
how the sister he's a
non-hijabi noticed me looking for the
qibla
and she came to me and said i look local
the kid was that way and she was a
non-hijabi like
if any brother we have this concept if
any brother saw on the road
it would be like they would never think
should praise allah
never so where do you think do you think
the sisters right in the context
where you should be saying that you know
and and there's there needs to be a thin
line because
then that there comes where system said
where people justify
okay i don't wear the hijab but i pray
no it's it's not an excuse
but sister farzana what would you say to
what you just heard i think
we have to be aware of the fact that as
muslims we shouldn't be judging anyone
anyway and some people do do that it
seems to be
you know it doesn't like sister namaste
mention
you know self-development is a big thing
and
those who are not there and they don't
understand themselves of what's coming
from them internally and they feel that
other people are reflecting
you know judgment on them so i think um
we have to understand that yeah okay
this sister is saying that um
there's sisters that are praying five
times a day and they don't wear a hijab
and they're better muslims than sisters
wearing a hijab
but then um personally i'm a sister who
does wear a hijab
and i don't look at sisters in that way
if there's a sister without
a hijab i will never ever think that i'm
better than her
so a lot of the times i feel that
sisters they do know what the right
thing is like sister naima mentioned
but they might have a fear of actually
going there themselves the fear of
how are people gonna react to me wearing
the hijab um
in a similar way to sisters who might
want to remove the hijab
they might be thinking how's someone
going to react to me removing the hijab
yeah no i just again it's that thing of
you know i know sisters who wear hijab
who
do haram things and i know sisters who
don't wear hijab
amazing muslims and of course we're
complex human beings
you know i think even as muslims we like
to think of ourselves as quite black and
white quite cut and dried
but to be honest brother andy especially
in this generation these
the millennials and the gen z's it's not
black and white anymore you know we know
you know people can be on it in certain
areas
and falling short severely in other
areas and
you can't really tell so in this day and
age
my advice really to every sister every
brother
is take care of your own affairs
you know if you're doing all you can do
and you know when you're making excuses
you know when you're being lazy you know
when you're just trying to get somebody
from somewhere you know enough snows you
know what i'm saying so
having conversations where we're saying
you know i know people who do this i
know people do that okay but what about
you
focus on what what are you doing and are
you
really pushing yourself to do the very
best you can that's the most important
thing
exactly okay i'm going to carry on the
video but this is very important because
a lot of people justify today so
like they'll say okay for example like
you said before um i don't want the
hijab but i pray and that is true you'll
have a lot of like sisters
in hijab you missed their salaam that's
a major sin yeah that is a major sin as
well the hijab is important as well
and then you have others who do not wear
the hijab but they do not miss their
salah
but the point is this why don't we
instead of comparing what she does that
he does
or the same with the brothers by the way
yeah or he has a beard or
he doesn't place her etc how about we
let's see for the sister wear the hijab
and pray for brothers have the beard and
pray and why does it have to be no but
she does that i don't so it's very
important for us to
not take blame let's be the better
person you know what you know my hijab
you pray i don't want you
let me wear hijab and try to pray and
same with the brothers of course um and
i think i'll resolve it let's watch this
video i think it's just the last bit and
then inshallah we're gonna get to the
real clocks of this video to your point
like
you're if you're talking let's talk
about hijab for example you don't do
that do you
yeah i'm sitting right now i'm i know
that if you have to say well
i'm more rebellious you know you're
doing something wrong and that's
shaythan trying to get you to
normalize it a lot of sins that we're
doing we're being normalized right no
that's definitely true a dude should not
be checking me out like i think the
hijab like prevents that
like for example without my hijab i go
to like a solid like eight out of ten
appearance like attraction-wise
and with the hijab i'm like you know a
two and i think it does a really good
job like when it makes me uglier i feel
like
good job great job you know if i'm
choosing to dress the way i dress and
that technically like
does not hurt anyone else you know it's
just
my personal choice i don't think you're
going to hell i think it's such a
personal
relationship between me and you know god
although you know that kind of thing
it frustrates me when people get
involved because i'm like it's none of
your business right
let me do me you know i wouldn't first
pay attention for example
to the very sister that we talked about
without the hijab this is what i admire
and respect where she goes
i'm sinning now you put your ass up to
that you know what because the problem
that we have today is people justify
no i am but you know look at least
you're saying i'm sinning and i'm
working on it yeah
so that's good but there's one thing and
you guys can elaborate on that there's
one thing that sister says um
the sister is not wearing the hijab yeah
she says i choose
to dress up like this now this is the
reason i'm doing
this whole video yeah and i'm going to
be talking a bit about this book and
reference something if anybody's if any
sister is watching this
you need to read this book yeah when she
says i
choose to dress up like this because you
see there's i was having a little
discussion with some ex-muslim
females and they they take these
pictures with a hijab before
and then their picture now of their
freedom
i would if it was just like you know
just dressing up lester paul's just like
a jumper nothing revealing
but all of their pictures are all in
revealing clothing
and they deem this to be i now i'm free
and i've made this choice now can we
agree system tell me if i'm wrong here
because i'm the reason i've got your
sits on here is that real me if needed
come and say no you're here but the
sister says i choose to wear the hijab i
believe that is not correct on the same
with the brother i can't come and say
i choose to pray fajr no i have free
will don't get it twisted i'm not
talking about that
i have the free will but i pray fajr
because allah tells me to not
i choose to in that sense i'm not
talking about the three willy i'm not
talking about
here so when a sister says i choose to
wear the hijab or brother says i choose
to grow a beard
no you do it because allah tells you to
do it am i wrong or correct
um i guess with this it just shows there
is
a lot of lack of understanding and
education when it comes to
us learning about the essence and true
meaning of islam
when you submit and when you commit
commit to your faith
then your choices are there but then you
make your choices and your behaviors
really does show as to where your
commitment lies
and yes we are definitely influenced by
society today as well
and that's why we think subconsciously
that is my choice but even psychologists
and people around that have studied
have shown how much we are influenced
and that's why
if you understand your faith well enough
you can maybe you know get a little bit
sidetracked but you'll understand that
it is a side track but you need to get
back on lane
so that's the thing i think we need to
give more
emphasis as to how we are educating our
youngsters
in our home and in the arabic schools or
islamic schools
with regards to from a very young age
the essence
behind the recitation of quran
understanding the meaning
understanding the benefits understanding
the protection and then you won't have
these kind of questions because as you
get to a certain age
there is an existential sort of um
awareness as to why am i here what am i
doing what does it mean
and if you're not getting the right role
models and influences around you
then these are the kind of things that
you'll be sort of saying and giving
yourself
that excuse for going and varying off in
a different direction than the faith and
the submission that you need to actually
uh you know commit to that system
yeah and i think i totally agree with
you sister hey man like
i think what a lot of people a lot of us
don't really realize is
nowadays we are we all have these kind
of demons that we have to fight right
firstly not it a modern society people
seem to have forgotten that the nerfs
is to be controlled not to be submitted
to
right so when we say you know i'm doing
me
this is my truth this is what i am this
is my authentic self this is who i
really am i'm you know i'm showing up as
my true self
hear that word itself in english it
sounds very innocuous
you know you see it everywhere but self
is
nuts in arabic that's the lust that's
the ego right
and we know from our deen that the nerfs
the nest needs to be humbled the nest
needs to be controlled because if you
give
in to your nuts it will take you down
the road of desires and lead you astray
so you've got perhaps on the one hand
then you've got shaytan which nobody
seems to realize is also
like playing a part here right and also
a lot of young people
do think they are making choices based
on their own individual process not
realizing as you said fahima
you know the programming the advertising
the whole societal conditioning that is
at work all the time that makes you
think you're making a free choice when
you're actually not
okay the song called roussel he's a
philosopher he said
man is born free but in shackles
everywhere
so now when the sister was saying that
because she was talking from a
you know a liberal point of view a
philosophical point of view where she's
saying basically
um you know i choose to or for example
you know she's talking about hellfire
etc
so the point is this we when we talk
about for example what that philosopher
said
man is born free but he's shackled
everywhere the point is this we are
all bound to be enslaved to something
we're bound to be
we are bound to be like me i came to
islam and i found my true freedom by
being
being a slave to the one who created me
because he deserves it rather than being
a slave
to a jumper that i used to wear that far
couldn't or going certain places or
driving certain things or going to the
gym
and i believe i was like well these are
all my masters because i'm trying to
make all of them happy
so the thing is this so we can agree and
say
that yes we follow the legislation of
like the hijab or be it brothers the
beard
praying or fasting whatever it may be we
do it because
allah tells us to yes so we can't really
say say it's a choice
so i want to come to the other side says
so when they say for example in the
system it's my choice to dress up like
this
this is where this book comes in beauty
sick
yeah because there is a generation
of like if you look at some studies here
it's mind-blowing yeah if you think
about it it's as
if they are saying okay we've left islam
like for example whatever it may be
and they make it seem as if they've
found freedom no you've just you've just
you're
not you're following another religion
now you know because if you think about
it
as muslims we have to foster ramadan
right this in this book it talks about
for example how girls who they they
they literally they fast but you know
why they fast
because of their body because
we imagine as a believer as muslims we
fast because allah tells us to
now there are some people who leave the
village i'm saying all of them here but
the thing is now
you go into this zone where for example
you are
the beauty industry listen by the beauty
industry how you being hypersexualized
sexualized society you've got the peer
pressure how i do not believe this
statement and tell me if i'm wrong
sister fazana to say
that you you are you made the choice
without any peer pressure to take off
your hijab
to for example dressing up but dress up
in a certain way
are you telling me that there was
nothing at play that made you
do that because when you think about
force we think someone's got gun to your
head
or you're forced and i'm not denying
there are people who force their
children to wear hijab
yeah i'm not talking about that yet but
if we're going to talk about a bigger
picture here
you are indirectly subconsciously being
forced to look and dress
a certain way that you can't even step
out the house without the makeup so
since if i
hope that answer the question as soon as
i go all over the place but
the question or should i reiterate it no
no no that's fine
um i think personally i think media
and family and friends can sometimes
influence the way
you you know say i made a choice and it
can be in a way forced upon you
in in a subconscious way where you don't
even realize that
you've kind of thought you've made a
choice but it's never been your choice
all the way along
it's been through the influence of
others and yes
media does play a major part in this but
i also believe that the surroundings you
have within the home
that's also going to play a major
influence in the way you dress
and the way you behave um you know in
some cases where a sister is trying to
wear a hijab
and the family members will have no
respect for that
they'll walk in on her without knocking
on the door
um they might even say to her oh you've
become holy all of a sudden
so there's a lot of pressure that
sisters and brothers may feel for
example a brother may start keeping a
beard and all of a sudden
the friends that he's been hanging
around with all these years are now
saying
hang on a minute when did you become
holy don't tell me
you know um so there's a lot of that so
yeah we can blame the media but i think
that
it's deeper than that and family and
friends can also influence you
rather than you saying okay i made this
choice um okay so
she said there was a survey over 200 000
young people
in 42 different countries i was saddened
but not surprised to read that among
15 year olds in every country surveyed
surveyed girls were more likely than
boys to report that they were too fat
one survey of over 50 000 adults found
that women were less satisfied overall
with how they look
compared to men and this
affects their life so if you think about
it there is a pandemic yeah
it's it's absolutely crazy you know and
there was a
there was a survey that was done for
example how you know in ads they use
these you know half naked
girls et cetera and they were talking
about they were studying done
in i can't remember which university it
was in america
and what they did is that they they
placed watches so these were from ten
thousand pounds to
five thousand pounds to a thousand
pounds or hundred pounds to ten pounds
ten ten dollars
women were they were less
emotionally upset when it was when they
were advertising
in a in a let's say a bikini or whatever
to an expensive watch
but when it was a cheaper watch they
felt more you know emotionally upset
so you like you can see for example
firstly
for them to be sexually objectified
they're not even beyond that like in
back in the days in jahlil when i used
to like
go to clubbing and stuff like that there
are certain rappers you would use the b
word and you will have girls in the club
that you're like
can you imagine the level of
indoctrination
that they are they are they are
accepting and
embracing a term with the b word and
they're embracing it like as if it's
something to be proud of
where is this like where do you think
this this is coming from and
it comes back to our point are they
truly free
when they say we choose to dress up like
this or look like this
and even just recently a a supermodel
who got you know plastic surgery in a
part of a body
died so can you see the pandemic and if
there's a sister watching with what
would you say to when
when they come and say okay i found my
freedom and i took off the hijab just
for him let's talk with you
um i think the way in which modern day
describe freedom is very different to
the way in which we look at it
there are certain ways that we have to
also understand that the human nature
and human beings
there isn't such a thing that we just
choose freely we are always
influenced in one particular way or
another that was my point to begin with
and
i think a lot of people lack that kind
of knowledge as to how human mind and
behavior and psychology works
because they think that they are free
they think they're making choices but we
know from
you know many levels whether it's policy
governments whether it's media and
especially as much as what everyone says
social media does affect a lot of us
this is what we're constantly being
bombarded with and there are some
you know subliminal messages all over us
where we
are now being programmed and
institutionalized
to act behave in a particular way and
even this whole i you know circumstance
that we're in in this pandemic
has shown how much we have to conform
and perform
in particular states of mind and i just
think that
each one has to be take on that role of
education especially
when it comes to your faith because as
much as people say oh i don't want to do
something that's been there
you know hundreds of years ago but it's
our history that's giving us the
solutions today
with regards to how we need to do things
when it comes to our faith
is not just you know a separation to our
lifestyle
as we know our faith is our life
if only we knew how to perform it
because if you pray
then that should add to your day that
should add to the benefits that should
do something but we're not taught that
way we're not looking at it that way
and we're only doing rituals that's why
we're not actually getting the benefits
and then we're varying again to another
section so
there's so many things to consider on
this but again i think a lot of people
need to really understand education
when it comes to there the woman who
wrote this she's doing a survey
she asked these uh participants think
about the ways in which you believe your
life will be different if you look like
this woman
how would things change for you so your
ideal woman yeah the response was so
upsetting this is from her the response
was so upsetting but i considered
stopping the study early
one young woman told us that if she
could just be beautiful she would
finally be able to focus on her inner
inner abilities and talent another said
she might genuinely feel happy
most of the time instead of just faking
it a different young woman explained
that if she could just look the way
our culture wants women to look she
would never have look she would never
have had an
eating disorder causing stress on
everyone around her
that she loves but still hurts over 70
of the women in the study said they'll
be treated better
but by others if they look like the
beauty ideal yeah
sister name are your revert to islam
yeah i don't know how long you've been a
revert
um but if you can tell us as a weaver
sister maybe
um like i said before maybe you're young
how long have you been
sister by the way 23 years
mashaallah so did you have a moment in
your life before you came to islam where
you felt pressured um and and to look a
certain way
and why did you choose islam because as
as a western like
a woman somebody come and say why would
you choose islam of all religions look
and look look how oppressed you are you
know we can only just see your eyes you
know so you're such a
you know there's this conception of your
wife your husband probably beats you up
and oh you're such a mischievous
feel sorry for you let's start a charity
for you is this the case why did you
embrace islam i don't mind someone
starting a charity for me that's fine
thank you
like that no um really uh
actually it's very interesting that you
asked that question because i considered
myself a feminist growing up
uh when i was a teenager what i
understood of feminism which was
basically you know women living
loud and proud i considered myself that
and it was actually
seeing women wearing hijab in egypt that
kind of opened my eyes to islam because
i got very angry
i got very very angry by seeing all
these covered women
you know more and more and more of them
and i and i did exactly what you said
i said you know why are these women
oppressed why do they make them dress
like this this is not
good they should be free to dress how
they want etc
and subhanallah it's it's really allah's
father that he chose
that to guide me because it really was
this fascination with
like like why would you want to dress
like that that made me actually speak to
someone and say you know you're so
beautiful
why do you cover yourself and she said
to me may allah bless her
this this this sister because this woman
in egypt in a city in egypt and
i asked her you're so beautiful why do
you cover yourself and she said to me
check this because i want to be judged
for what i
say and what i do not what i look like
and for me that was like like
what is this mindset what is the
strength what is this
courage what is this this woman who does
not
need what me and all my friends need
which is appreciation male validation
admiration all these things that we were
taught to crave them to see
she didn't need any of that exactly and
you know you know i'm gonna go back to
the book i'm so sorry look what she said
here yeah
beauty sickness is what happens when a
woman is emotionally emotional energy
gets all bound up with what they see in
the mirror that it becomes harder for
them to see the other aspects of their
lives
yeah this is this is crazy i'm not gonna
quote from this book anymore by the way
we're gonna wrap up in a minute
but the thing is it's so powerful that
as a like for example like our sisters
you guys on here
like as muslim men like we we try to own
our sister and be respectful in the way
it's found the way we conduct ourselves
and the thing is it's like
it's you when we look at you we should
look at you as a human being
you're a person not okay you know for
example i need to you know impress
someone with
you know my makeup or whatever it may be
et cetera yeah and that's normal
everyone has their struggles etc but
what i'm trying to say is that it's not
you don't
like sometimes i look at certain females
and i'm like wow the only thing you have
to offer
is your body parts and that's so sad
that society has brought you to such a
low level
that you think the only thing you have
to offer
is your body parts and as islam has come
to get rid of that break those shackles
and to say you're a human being
you have much more to offer so for
closing statements and once that was
sister
farzana if sister nine might finish your
point or there's anything else you want
to say
yeah because you asked about the um you
know the difference between being you
know non-muslim and being muslim and i
think that you know what we need to
really realize today is that
the same pressures that i felt as a
young woman growing up
are felt today by muslim girls
times 100 if not 1 000 and i'm gonna put
it on social media store sorry
sorry not sorry but it is social media
and our girls are suffering from it too
so you see what you said there
about knowing what you have to offer
and knowing that it's so much more than
the way that you look
that is something that we should be
teaching our boys and especially our
girls
from the home through schools through as
you said for him
you know madaras etc because it is a
huge
mushkiller in our society today may i
bless you sister foreign statements
anything
there's young girls watching this and
you know just
your closing statement i think there's
a lot of pressure on you know young
sisters
to kind of like conform to what society
wants them to be and yeah
there is a slight movement in that in
the
kind of like uh western side of things
where ladies are
you know big is beautiful and all this
kind of stuff
but i think if there's still that
a kind of essence of beautiful
what is beauty you know beauty is from
the soul
that you could have the most amazing
person to look at
and yet you know when they speak oh
their personality of their character
it's ugly so we have to as individuals
you know put that forward in the sense
you know in the past i've had parents
say to their children
why are you dressed like that that
doesn't look right go change your
clothes or
you know they'll grill their child for
not looking like or what it should do
even you i've seen
two-year-olds three-year-olds where
parents are dressing them up
as this perfect instagram baby
and it's it gets ridiculous to the point
where
parents themselves or you know as a
society as a whole
we're not realizing that what what kind
of vibe are we moving off
so you know we we have to look at
ourselves as well that where
where do we draw the line
yes media is is the influencing in a
major way but then
how much how many of us are actually
taking the back seat and thinking
no i don't want to look like that i want
to look like this whether whether
a muslim or whatever religion that might
be
i think you know we have to look at
ourselves and then you know understand
that way we can make
that change of um within the homes as
well
because you know these the the media how
does it come into the home we're
bringing it into the home
we're not supervising our children we're
not supervising these teenagers
you know and as children we're not into
it you know with our younger children
toddlers
parents are not interacting with them so
when the child grows up
and becomes a teenager that teenager no
longer wants to interact with the parent
so now when you when when you say to
your teenager you know you should be
dressing like that when you go out
they're gonna ignore you the way you
ignore them as a child so
there's a lot we can we can talk about
this forever
statements i think in this day and age
we are definitely able to adapt
and the way in which we can adapt is to
understand especially as muslims that
life is a struggle
it's not easy to wear the hijab and we
need to embrace that because we always
want to be comfortable
and we always want to fit in and that
also comes with your lack of
confidence self-esteem and more
importantly know your meaning
and purpose in life study that
understand that when you have your
meaning and purpose in life
no matter what platform you're on no
matter where you're sitting at
you don't need to be there for everyone
and that is okay
and that's the issue right now because
we want to constantly
be acknowledged you know given that kind
of like you know tap on the back of
those hundred likes and shares and
whatever it may be
we need that acknowledgement because we
are not fulfilled and happy within
ourselves
and when you know your meaning and
purpose in life when you are strong
and you have that kind of understanding
of your own
faith and belief which gives you all the
answers the key
is there that just have to open the
treasures and it gives you all the
answers
i would say go and read and learn and
look there's many things out there even
use social media to your advantage
to listen to lecturers the right people
the right influences
the right role models and you will get
that answer and the right direction
inshallah
may allah bless you guys all of you is
amazing martial
amazing perspective from you guys uh and
inshallah if there's any more other
topics regarding you know this area
where sisters are needed definitely
would
love for you guys to come again
inshallah bless you guys and for those
who are watching
uh once again like i said before um i i
i put emphasis uh on what the sister
said last about the choice
because we go under this impression um
that we think we're making decisions but
we don't understand that
you know subconsciously we are being
forced and we don't realize and then
we're like
i choose to when whenever you think
think about this sisters yeah
for those who for example i'm not
talking about those who just taking
hijab this video is mainly down for
those who are ex-muslim females thinking
that they're liberating themselves
by leaving the hijab and thinking that
it was their conscious decision to make
that
and i'm saying was it really think about
it for example and especially
when these females for example had a
discussion one of them in speaker's
corner
she came and she was dressed in such a
way that
i i she was there and i had to talk like
this
i couldn't look at her it was impossible
for me to look at her and i was thinking
did she am i going to be that she
consciously made that decision
to dress up like that why would you want
to show a certain part of your body
in display to that man now your freedom
to do whatever i'm just thinking
was it a free choice or was it
manipulated in a certain way
subconsciously that you think you made
the choice
but you actually didn't and that's what
this video was about today brother
sisters if you would like sister farzana
assistant
sister fema to do reaction videos um
to other topics regarding this issue
where a sister's perspective said i've
listened to you guys there's the sisters
there's three of them
and i've brought them here um and may
allah bless all of them inshallah
they came hamdra in a decent manner
conducted a beautiful social
reaction video and hope you guys
benefited from that on the comment
section
tell us if there's any other videos you
would like us to react to until next
time assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh please share this with your
friends and family and if you have young
siblings females share it with
with them inshallah inshallah benefit
them till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi kid